in our last episode we battle-tested
every generation of the iPhone but here
on Battle Damage we are equal
opportunity destroyer thanks to some
suggestions
Lucas Cheatham Jovi Bible and Bugsy the
artist today we'll be putting Androids
to the test we've got five of the most
popular versions of the samsung galaxy s
and we'll be seeing which one can take
the most abuse let's do it
what began is just an iPhone ripoff is
now coming into its own by pushing the
limits on screen size and features in
fact every model of the Galaxy S has
sold faster than the one before but keep
in mind that at least five of those were
bought for the sole purpose of being
destroyed right now what is the deal
with that oh my 3d printer stopped
working a couple days before the shoot
so the galaxies didn't get the special
3d printed version that the iPhones got
and I got the Lego versions
I missed my green button yeah I'm not
gonna lie I'm sorry action
all right let's start with the one it's
good this tattoo looks totally fine 3
I'm totally fine
the 4 passes with flying colors and the
5 back in pop 3 feet right there I'll
pass let's pick up 15 feet
and as our resident Android fanboy
what's your prediction on how many will
break none honestly none I think these
are all going to the tank race I think
at least two are gonna break roll
I'm feeling a couple backs phone off
where's the first one one battery few
out faces off oh and screen is cracked
ah okay one is out ones out this is -
looks fine
ace popped out a little bit not bad - is
in three looks good all right so the
four screen crack if I can hear it
working but black screen yeah I just saw
flicker and this one's out five the
newest one I think also oh yeah if I can
hear it going the same thing as before
so just an intro boy you thought none of
these would break now I thought - would
break and three growth so it's even
worse how many survived the 15-foot
iPhone drama I don't know you got to
watch the episode
so why do we have liquid nitrogen air we
anticipated that the s5 would make it to
the final test
just water proof s5 got knocked out
second round so now our older
non-waterproof galaxy's I mean we got
the liquid nitrogen so let's do it roll
action
I think just take might explode okay
from examining don't exploding or the
phone still on no visual things are
cracking eggs cook you know since this
will be functioning they're still on so
the phones are all asking to take wait
initial yeah I'm still on
I think you guys out okay
really how about at 41 seconds okay - is
choose out at 51 seconds Wow
alright so if you ever need to know how
long your Galaxy s2 will last in liquid
nitrogen 51 seconds that's bad
not bad it's cold it's damn cold so
we're gonna shame our losers but they
just don't feel frozen enough so we're
gonna add a little more liquid nitrogen
that's beautiful
action
you
haha yeah look at all those backings wow
that's the most galaxies I've destroyed
since I designed that tractor beam for
the government name what I've said too
much government just like a galaxy
killing alright that's it for this
episode
tune in next time and we'll find out
what's tougher the GoPro or its
competitors where am i Who am I
maybe I've done this too many times it's
convenient though